bonjour messieurs bonjour chers
collègues
merci d'être voilà d'être présent
un mardi matin avant les
échéances de discussion à venir qui vont
nous occuper beaucoup donc pour cette
commission d'enquête pénurie de
médicaments
et pourtant aussi sur les choix de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
nous poursuivons donc aujourd'hui nos
travaux
par l'audition donc de Monsieur Philippe
bouillou que nous remercions de sa
présence président du comité économique
des produits de santé le CEPS et de
Monsieur Jean-Patrick salle
vice-président chargé du médicament que
je remercie également de sa présence le
CEPS est un organisme interministériel
et inter-institutionnel placé sous
l'autorité conjointe des ministres
chargées de la santé de la sécurité
sociale et de l'économie le CEPS est
principalement chargé par la voix de
négocier et de fixer le prix des
médicaments lequel constitue un levier
essentiel de notre politique de santé
publique comme de notre politique
industrielle
et notamment parce que le prix du
médicament
est suivi par la question du prix
remboursé du médicament dans notre pays
au travers des politiques de
remboursement et des sommes qui sont
allouées dans le cas du projet loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale le CEPS
est compétent sur un champ large mais
délimité il s'agit de médicaments
remboursable délivrés en officine de
ville des médicaments inscrits sur la
liste en Suisse et des médicaments dit
de rétrocession distribués en pharmacie
hospitalière le prix d'un médicament
étant un élément d'attractivité pour sa
commercialisation en France et on a déjà
eu l'occasion notamment au travers des
questions des concurrences
transfrontalières mais aussi et c'est
important le prix du médicament est un
élément d'A possibilité pour
l'implantation industrielle de Saver de
sa fabrication nous nous proposons donc
de vérifier si le modèle de régulation
économique des dépenses de santé du prix
du médicament dont le CEPS est une pièce
centrale est en cause dans le déclin de
la production pharmaceutique française
et dans les tensions de rupture qui
affectent de manière chronique
l'approvisionnement du marché français
en médicament ce sont juste des
questions en suspens pour mener son
action le comité conclut des conventions
avec les entreprises qui commercialisent
des médicaments pris en charge par
l'Assurance Maladie celle-ci porte sur
le prix des médicaments et sur son
évolution sur les remises sur les
engagements des entreprises concernant
le bon usage des médicaments et les
volumes de vente ou encore sur les
modalités de participation des
entreprises à la mise en oeuvre des
orientations ministérielles ce qui est
évidemment un lien entre les politiques
de santé publique et la prescription et
l'usage que l'on fait des médicaments
dans notre pays alors que le nombre de
ruptures au risque de rupture des Claris
augmentent très fortement ces dernières
années faisant de ce phénomène un
problème structurel qui compromet
l'accès de nos consultations assez bien
de première nécessité les ministres de
la santé de l'industrie réunissant le 3
février dernier un comité de pilotage
sur la gestion et la prévention des
pénuries médicaments ont annoncé un
moratoire sur les baisses de prix des
génériques stratégiques sur le plan
industriel et sanitaire ils ont
également indiqué leur volonté d'opérer
des hausses de prix ciblées sur certains
génériques stratégiques produits en
Europe c'est hausse de prix devance
devant ce faire en contrepartie
d'engagement des industriels sur une
sécurisation de l'improvisation de
l'approvisionnement du marché français y
compris en se posant la question de la
production sur notre territoire nous
souhaiterions que vous puissiez dresser
dans une brève présentation introductive
un tableau de votre action
et de la façon dont vous menez ces
négociations conventionnelles sur les
prix qui sont souvent qui interrogent
critiquer ou en tout cas qui interroge
sur sur une forme de ce qui est enfin
sur ce qui est ressenti comme étant une
opacité vous êtes les mieux placés en
particulier pour nous donner une idée de
l'impact du prix de remboursement des
médicaments qu'ils soient mature ou
innovants puisque les deux sont liés
pour certains laboratoires qui
produisent et les médicaments matures et
les médicaments innovants par exemple
sur les stratégies commerciales des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et donc sur
l'approvisionnement des pharmacies
françaises vous pourrez notamment nous
éclairer sur ce cas changer l'accord
câble signer le 5 mars 2021 entre le
CEPS et le LEM qui est le syndicat des
laboratoires
après ce propos liminaire je donnerai la
parole donc à notre rapporteur Laurence
Cohen qui est donc à partir de notre
commission d'enquête et qui vous posera
une première série de de questions et
qu'il en sera nos échanges je précise
que nous vous adresserons à l'issue de
l'audition à questionnaire complet
auquel nous vous demanderons de répondre
par écrit avant le 17 mars je précise
également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et elle fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu public et publié avant de
vous donner la parole monsieur le
Président Monsieur louis-président je
vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête et
passive des peines prévues aux articles
434 qui tirés 13 430 4-14 et 434-15 du
code pénal et je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure
je le jure
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
vous avez donc la parole
et nous vous écoutez
je vous remercie madame présidente
Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs comme vous le
suggérez je vais commencer par un propos
linéaire vous avez vous-même introduit
ce qui était le CEPS donc de manière
assez complète donc j'essaierai de ne
pas faire de redit et de me concentrer
sur des points de complémentaires par
rapport à votre votre intervention
dans cette première intervention si vous
le permettez je pensais faire deux
choses d'une part vous donner quelques
éléments de nature générale sur le CEPS
comme vous l'avez suggéré et d'autre
part faire un bref inventaire des
leviers dont nous disposons dans notre
dans notre action de tarification ou de
régulation des leviers nous disposons
face à un risque de pénurie je vais pas
le détailler durant cette intervention
liminaire mais évidemment nous serons
prêts à répondre à vos questions
ultérieurement alors sur le CEPS de
manière générale vous en avez fait la
présentation institutionnelle la
conséquence de ce que vous venez de
d'exposer c'est que
nous nous allons vous répondre à travers
un prisme qui est celui du CEPS et je
dirais un double prisme par rapport à
ces situations de pénurie et de manière
générale d'une part comme vous l'avez
rappelé nous sommes en charge des
questions de prix tarification en
première inscription ou régulation et
d'autre part nous conduisons une
politique conventionnelle
sur le prix c'est donc notre outil pour
remplir les missions de tarification et
de régulation qui sont les nôtres et
c'est un outil pour plusieurs objectifs
ce qui est toujours une situation
délicate et nos objectifs sont des
objectifs de la politique générale de
santé et d'économie de la santé avec des
objectifs sur l'accès aux soins bien
entendu mais aussi sur la maîtrise de la
dépense et l'attractivité du territoire
pour chacun de ces objectifs certains
parlent d'injonction et même
d'injonctions contradictoires que nous
devons gérer pour chacun de ces
objectifs nous avons donc un levier le
prix en ayant conscience que à travers
ce levier nous apportons nous pouvons
apporter devant apporter une
contribution à l'atteinte des ces
objectifs mais que nous ne pouvons pas
être le seul levier de ces politiques si
je prends juste et très rapidement
l'exemple des questions d'attractivité
du territoire pour la production en
France et bien très clairement il y a
d'autres leviers qui peuvent être
actionnés et qui ont trait à la qualité
des écosystèmes de santé écosystème
d'innovation et puis plus généralement
la politique d'attractivité que ce soit
les dispositifs de type crédit un peu
recherche des plans comme France 2030 la
politique de cluster etc donc
nous intervenons avec le prix dans un
environnement au service de ses
objectifs qui est plus large que ce seul
outil du prix
je vous ai dit ensuite que le CEPS
le deuxième prisme que j'avais cité
était celui de la politique
conventionnelle le CEPS et un lieu de
politique conventionnelle c'est-à-dire
que notre métier c'est de négocier nous
négocions d'abord des règles du jeu
parce qu'on appelle l'accord cadre et
vous avez fait référence au dernier qui
a été signé en 2021 et ensuite nous
négocions produit par produit donc pour
nous un succès c'est pas juste un prix
que nous avons trouvé c'est une
négociation qui se conclut par un accord
c'est à dire la signature d'une
convention avec ce avec ce prix là alors
comment conduisons-nous ces missions
notre notre action est encadrée par
différents textes et de différents
niveaux
il y a un niveau législatif et
réglementaire derrière avec puisque nous
respectons des principes et des critères
qui sont des critères qui figurent dans
la loi il y a un certain nombre de
critères qui déterminent le niveau de
prix que nous devons rechercher ces
critères sont hiérarchisés le premier
d'entre eux c'est
après à la valeur thérapeutique et
l'apport de d'un produit donné tel qu'on
peut l'apprécier à partir de la SMR
l'amélioration du service médical rendu
qui lui est attribué par la Commission
de transparence de la HAS
donc c'est le premier critère la valeur
thérapeutique nous nous appuyons sur le
niveau de la SMR et c'est quelque chose
qui pour nous est un input
cela découle d'une analyse scientifique
le CEPS lui n'est pas un comité de
nature scientifique donc nous prenons un
input et nous le prenons comme une
donnée
il importe que les laboratoires le
intègre bien le fait que nous ne pouvons
pas revenir sur les niveaux d'un SMR qui
l'auront été attribués nous avons un
deuxième niveau d'encadrement ce sont
les orientations ministérielles qui nous
sont adressées par les ministres les
ministres en charge du de la santé en
charge de l'Industrie et en charge des
comptes publics vous l'avez rappelé la
dernière lettre d'orientation
ministérielle date du début 2021
nous avons ensuite toujours en termes de
d'encadrement de notre action et bien la
corcadre vous avez fait référence qui
est négocié avec les avec les
représentants des entreprises et qui
d'une en quelque sorte fixe ce que
seront les règles du jeu pour la
définition pratique pour la pour la mise
en oeuvre pratique des critères
législatif c'est par exemple c'est à
travers la corde que nous pouvons
accorder des avantages conventionnels
par exemple nous pouvons attribuer une
stabilité de prix différenciée suivant
le niveau d'ASMR du médicament ou encore
nous pouvons accorder des durées de
stabilité sur la base d'investissement
réalisé en Europe et notamment en France
l'idée à travers ces règles du jeu qui
qui composent la corde c'est de ne pas
avoir à réinventer les éléments de la
négociation à chaque fois nous arrivons
sur un produit nouveau le dernier niveau
qui d'une certaine manière encadre notre
action c'est ce que nous appelons la
doctrine d'une manière peut-être un peu
impropre c'est à dire que après les
différents niveaux que je viens
d'évoquer le législatives
législatif réglementaire l'accord cadre
les orientations ministérielles malgré
tout la déclinaison pratique conduit à
traiter des sujets qui n'ont pas été
explicités par les niveaux précédents et
du coup là c'est la pratique du comité
que nous consignions dans nos rapports
annuels et c'est l'ensemble qui
constitue notre doctrine
deux mots sur le CEPS vous avez parlé de
sa dimension terre ministérielle le CEPS
est un donc un comité au sein duquel
nous avons
différents organismes nous avons trois
organismes payeurs entre guillemets la
CNAM linocam pour les complémentaires et
je mettrai dans cette catégorie la
direction de la de la sécurité sociale
ces trois payeurs ont cinq voix puisque
nos décisions sont prises par vote ils
ont 5 voies et il y a trois autres
membres trois autres directions qui ont
une voie chacune et qui ont des
tropismes qui peuvent être qui peuvent
qui sont différents les uns des autres
vous avez la Direction générale de la
santé dans tropisme principal et l'accès
aux soins la direction générale des
entreprises qui est
particulièrement compétente sur les
questions industrielles et d'autres
activités et la DGCCRF
qui veille scrupuleusement à ce que nous
introdisions pas de distorsion dans le
système et j'ajoute puisque j'ai parlé
de vote que le vice-président et le
président ont une voix chacun en cas
d'égalité si on était par exemple dans
une situation
cinq trois et que nous irions tous les
deux prendre le parti des trois ça fait
500 et dans ce cas là c'est l'heure de
gloire du vice-président puisqu'il se
prend pour du président du président
puisque il se prend j'ai pas l'habitude
de parler de moi à la troisième personne
puisqu'il peut se prendre pour le
président vice-président des États-Unis
avec une voix qui compte double
j'ajoute que nous avons beaucoup de
travail que nous avons beaucoup de
médicaments à traiter pour vous donner
un ordre de grandeur sur le médicament
nous devons examiner à peu près 700
dossiers par an alors certains sont
beaucoup plus rapides que d'autres la
fixation du prix des produits génériques
est beaucoup plus encadré et du coup
prend beaucoup moins de temps en
principe mais les noms génériques nous
en avons un peu moins de 400 dans
l'année donc à tout moment alors là j'ai
pas de statistiques précises mais je
pense qu'à tout moment nous avons entre
50 et 100 négociations de médicaments
qui sont en cours à des stades d'hiver
et j'ai parlé du médicament nous avons
le même dispositif dans le cadre des
dispositifs médicaux
voilà sur le ce que je souhaitais vous
dire en introduction sur le CEPS si vous
me laissez encore deux minutes pour
cette intervention préliminaire je
voudrais balayer les principales
dispositions ou les principaux leviers
que nous avons concernant le sujet des
pénuries ou des risques de pénurie alors
on a évoqué la lettre d'orientation
ministérielle
celle-ci celle de 2021
fixe un certain nombre de principes
généraux après avoir rappelé que notre
mission s'inscrivait dans une politique
générale de santé publique et d'économie
de la santé elle précise que la mission
principale on est l'accès aux soins dans
les meilleures conditions et que cela
signifie des choses qui peuvent être
différentes pour les thérapies
innovantes et pour les produits plus
anciens à l'efficacité avérées ce qui
nous est demandé pour les thérapies les
plus innovantes c'est de veiller à ce
que la rapport à nouveau soit justement
rémunéré sur notre territoire et pour ce
qui est des médicaments plus anciens à
l'efficacité avérée il nous est demandé
de veiller à leur pérennité la pérennité
de leur disponibilité sur notre
territoire et
avec tout cela dans le cadre bien
entendu de la cadre global de la
contrainte budgétaire avec deux messages
supplémentaires et qui nous amènent sur
le sujet des pénuries ou des risques de
pénurie il nous est demandé d'avoir un
souci constant de permettre au système
de soins de bénéficier d'une offre
diversifiée
et il nous est indiqué que les
empreintes industrielles en France sont
un atout dès lors qu'elles permettent de
sécuriser la disponibilité des produits
au meilleures conditions et dans la
durée c'était la première fois je pense
que les questions de sécurité
d'approvisionnement est figuré
explicitement dans une lettre
d'orientation ministérielle adressée au
CEPS donc ces instructions nous les
avons eu quand nous étions encore dans
la négociation de la corcadre et nous
avons essayé et nous avons dans la
mesure du possible transposer dans les
dispositions de la corcadre cela à la
fois à travers un certain nombre de
mesures de portée plus générale je pense
à la façon dont nous reconnaissons c'est
à dire dont nous pouvons accorder des
avantages conventionnels
aux médicaments qui résultent
d'investissement en Europe et en France
avantage qui peuvent prendre la forme
d'une stabilité de prix avantage qui
prennent aussi la forme d'avoir sur
remise ce que l'on appelle d'avoir sur
remise au titre du xis ce qu'on appelle
communément les prédicsis et il y a
ensuite un article plus spécifique qui
indique dans quelles conditions si nous
sommes confrontés au risque de retrait
par un exploitant d'un produit d'un
médicament dans quelles conditions nous
pouvons accorder des hausses de prix
donc les articles que je viens d'évoquer
rapidement sont les articles 27 28 29 de
l'accord-cadre et nous pourrons
évidemment en reparler plus en détail si
vous le souhaitez
c'était j'ai fait référence à la l'homme
à la corde qui sont de
2021 depuis cette période un certain
nombre de dispositions nouvelles ont été
mises en place il y a un article du
PLFSS
2022 qui était l'article 65 et qui
modifie la liste des critères législatif
sur lesquels nous fondons notre action
donc il s'agit d'apporter un critère
supplémentaire on parle souvent du
critère industriel j'y reviendrai
c'était dans la loi
nous avons pris le temps de du travail
technique pour mettre au point le mode
opératoire de d'application de cette de
cet article et c'est maintenant le cas
donc nous à communiquer sur la façon
dont en pratique nous allons mettre en
oeuvre ce critère industriel qui a été
ajouté par le LFSS 2022
j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure que nous
avions un article permettant des hausses
de prix face aux risques de retrait d'un
médicament il s'agit de l'article 28 de
l'accord cadre et cet article également
nous venons dans l'élargir le le champ à
la fois en termes d'éligibilité et de et
de mise en œuvre
toujours dans les dispositions nouvelles
vous savez que un travail est en cours
pour la définition d'une liste de
produits critiques
à la fois au plan sanitaire et
stratégique
donc avec le croisement de
d'une approche pour définir des produits
qui sont essentiels en termes de santé
et d'autre part le croisement avec une
appréciation de la vulnérabilité de la
chaîne de valeur donc c'est également
quelque chose que nous allons devoir
être intégrer à notre boîte à outils je
dirais et vous avez mentionné madame la
présidente des annonces récentes des
ministres concernant les produits
génériques donc ces annonces nous allons
bien entendu
les mettre en oeuvre et nous nous
appuierons pour cela sur les différents
articles que je viens de d'évoquer donc
je vais m'arrêter là en résumé sur cette
2 sur mon deuxième point d'intervention
nous avons des dispositions pour
reconnaître les investissements donc
leur attribut des avantages
conventionnels nous avons des
dispositions pour éventuellement
pratiquer des hausses de prix face à des
risques de retrait nous avons ensuite la
déclinaison d'un article de la LSS qui
nous conduit à valoriser dès la fixation
du prix la sécurité d'approvisionnement
que peut garantir l'implantation des
sites de production donc ce sont
différents points sur lesquels nous
sommes bien entendu tout à fait disposés
à vous apporter les détails utiles
très bien je vous remercie beaucoup pour
pour ses propos qui ont voilà un
numérique de poser un certain nombre de
sujets notamment la liste des critères
auxquels sur lesquels vous vous appuyez
ainsi que les évolutions
en matière de convention je vais donner
immédiatement la parole à notre
rapporteur
qui
va vous poser une première salle de
questions et lancer l'échange avec vous
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président donc moi je vais vous
poser un certain nombre de questions
peut-être d'abord sur la fixation
effectivement des prix et la maîtrise
des dépenses de santé chaque année au
niveau du Parlement nous nous votons le
PLFSS et dans ce cadre Londres
pas mais bon en tout cas il est soumis
il est soumis au vote des parlementaires
c'était une petite
donc
ma question repose donc sur cette Honda
mais l'objectif agrégé d'évolution des
dépenses d'assurance maladie qui est
donc qui est donc voté et je voudrais
savoir comment vous vous le vous le
traduisez les traduit évidemment par le
ministère mais par le comité finalement
comment vous faites pour éventuellement
le traduire par des baisses de prix
médicament par médicament puisque dans
le dernier PLFSS il y a eu une demande
d'économie de plusieurs centaines de
millions sur cette enveloppe donc
comment vous faites pour produits par
produit répercuter ces décisions
parlementaires
je pense aussi peut-être que je vais
poser encore plus directement la
question qui nous taraude tout et tous
vous avez une mission qui est
extrêmement difficile me semble-t-il en
tout cas puisque vous êtes dans la
négociation des prix vous êtes en
quelque sorte pris entre deux feux d'un
côté les directives gouvernementales que
vous devez de respecter et de l'autre
côté les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
qui ont quand même un pouvoir
extrêmement important aussi et
[Musique]
le sujet finalement qui nous taraude
c'est de savoir que en réalité il y a
pas de transparence dans dans tout ça
concernant
ce que peuvent investir les laboratoires
dans tel ou tel produit je vais par
exemple prendre
l'élément du sofos GIR qui est donc un
traitement contre l'hépatite C c'était
en 2014 il y avait 42000 euros
qui était proposé en termes de prix pour
12 semaines de traitement alors qu'il
semblerait que le prix de la production
n'était que de 100 euros on commence
dans ce cas là en terme de décalage
parce que vous nous avez bien dit que
vous évaluez ce qui est une bonne chose
la valeur thérapeutique du service rendu
mais là on voit bien quand même on n'est
pas sur une petite un petit
différentielle quand je parle de 100
euros 42000 euros on est quand même loin
du compte donc quels sont finalement vos
marges de manœuvre par rapport au mandat
que vous recevez du gouvernement et
ça je crois que c'est une question pour
pour moi en tout cas extrêmement
extrêmement importante et du coup quand
je parlais d'opacité ça ça me conduit à
parler de la notion de transparence
la notion de transparence des données
par exemple dans la dans la presse la
semaine dernière et c'est régulièrement
dans la presse l'Observatoire sur la
transparence des prix des médicaments
estimait qu'en France nous manquions je
cite d'éléments concrets solides et
précis sur les coûts réels de production
le prix de la matière première
pharmaceutique et les aides publiques
reçues par les industriels parce que
c'est cette évaluation là qui vont qui
vont permettre effectivement aussi de
construire de construire le prix donc
est-ce que vous avez aujourd'hui des
données qui sont pertinentes pour mener
justement à bien ses missions de
fixation des prix de remboursement à la
fois donc dans leur dans leur champ et
dans leur qualité et quels sont les les
éléments qui vous sont qui vous sont
transmis par les producteurs et est-ce
que vous avez besoin vous auriez besoin
on va dire de d'accéder à des données
supplémentaires pour pour bien
objectiver les prix et finalement en
clair qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait comme
transparence pour avoir une une
évaluation du modèle économique des
industries
le nouvel accord cadre vous en avez vous
en avez déjà vous en avez déjà parlé
mais il y a aussi un élément peut-être
que vous n'avez pas abordé ou en tout
cas je n'y ai pas prêté suffisamment
d'attention et j'aimerais que vous
précisiez votre propos c'est les
investissements publics en termes de R&D
qui sont perçus et à partir de de là
comment est-ce que vous avez ces données
et comment vous évaluez toujours à la
lumière de ces aides publiques
la fixation des prix en 2021 SOL7
entreprises ont déclaré des aides
publiques et maintenant surtout
d'ailleurs de
BPI France dans le cas des aides à la
relocalisation ou aux entreprises dans
le cadre du covid-19 pour au total
environ 3 millions d'euros on voit bien
là que c'est mon temps sont extrêmement
faibles au regard des dispositifs de
soutien qui ont été
accordée par le par le gouvernement et
donc on a le sentiment en tout cas vous
allez me dire si c'est un sentiment
c'est une réalité mais je penserai pour
la deuxième deuxième possibilité c'est
que l'impression c'est qu'en tout cas ça
n'inclut pas les montants du crédit pour
recherche alors est-ce que vous pouvez
justement au niveau du CEPS exercer un
quelconque que contrôle sur ces sur ces
données relatives aux aides publiques
perçues ou est-ce du purement déclaratif
et est-ce que vous avez la possibilité
d'avoir un suivi précis au sein de
l'administration donc vous voyez que moi
les questions qui me semblent
extrêmement importantes d'éclairer pour
notre commission d'enquête c'est tout ce
qui concerne finalement la transparence
des données et votre accès propre à à
ces données ça c'était la première la
première série alors est-ce que je
m'arrête là parce que j'aimerais aussi
poser quelques questions sur les
génériques mais peut-être c'est une
première série je vous laisse la parole
parce qu'elle est elle est je sens
qu'elle est elle est conséquente mais
vous pouvez apporter un certain nombre
comme comme d'ailleurs la présidente la
souligne et vous pouvez apporter un
certain nombre d'éléments parce que ça
je pense que vous voulez maîtrisez
parfaitement bien et puis par ailleurs
nous répondre par écrit si les questions
sont un peu plus
demande un peu plus de données chiffrées
clairs
je vais juste compléter moi je me posais
effectivement la question de quels sont
vos moyens humains et techniques pour
évaluer la qualité d'un projet induite
industriel ou d'innovation
[Musique]
pour ce premier sur cette première vague
de questions
assez substantielle en effet alors les
premiers points madame la rapporteur
vous avez vous avez demandé comment nous
traduisions les objectifs qui nous sont
fixés par la LFSS notamment en matière
de baisse de prix sachant que comme vous
l'avez rappelé nous intervenons à la
fois pour de la fixation et de prix et
la maîtrise de la dépense alors juste
pour préciser ce point là donc
effectivement nous faisons de la
tarification en première en primo
inscription pour un nouveau produit ou
une nouvelle indication d'un produit
donné à ce stade là on est vraiment dans
une logique produit par produit et ce
que nous demande de faire la loi ce que
nous demande de la loi c'est de fixer le
prix par rapport aux critères législatif
que j'ai évoqué le premier d'entre eux
ét l'amélioration du service médical
rendu mais il y a d'autres critères dont
maintenant le critère industriel dans
cette action là sur un produit donné
nous ne sommes pas en train de
nous nous posons pas la question de
l'impact macroéconomique on peut avoir
certains produits extrêmement chers donc
on sera d'autant plus vigilant mais nous
ne sommes pas dans du pilotage produit
par produit d'un objectif
macroéconomique à ce stade là ce que
nous faisons c'est que nous veillons en
termes de maîtrise de la dépense nous
veillons à favoriser l'accès aux soins
en ne surveillant pas un produit donc
nous négociants absolument sans
complaisance avec les laboratoires sur
la base des critères légaux et sur la
base de leur déclinaisons dans la
corcadre c'est le premier stade ensuite
et je pense que c'est plutôt sur ce
deuxième point que porter votre question
il y a l'exercice dit de régulation
c'est à dire les objectifs déchiffrer
qui nous sont donnés par le gouvernement
une fois par an alors pour vous indiquer
comment ça se passe et comment nous ce
EPS nous nous positionnons dans cet
exercice l'objectif qui nous est donné
pour le médicament cette année pour
l'année 2023 nous devons réaliser 800
millions de
d'économie sous forme de baisse de prix
c'est 800 millions
c'est un montant qui est déterminé par
d'autres que nous à la fois en termes
d'analystes techniques et de choix
politiques
l'analyse technique elle est contenue
dans le PLFSS et les produits notamment
par la Direction de la Sécurité sociale
et le choix politique il est celui du
Parlement et l'idée à ce moment-là c'est
de regarder quelle est le montant
d'économie qui serait nécessaire pour
ramener une croissance de la dépense qui
s'effectue suivant une tendance
spontanée pour ramener
niveau de dépense au niveau qui est
celui d'une trajectoire qui a été
déterminée par choix politique par le
Parlement sur proposition du
gouvernement donc vous avez un tendre
ancien et vous avez une trajectoire pour
pour fixer les choses sur la période
2022 2024 l'objectif qui avait été
retenu c'était un taux de croissance
annuel moyen pour les produits de santé
de 2,4% par an il y a eu suffisamment de
polémiques cette année sur la façon de
calculer mais ce que je voulais dire par
là c'est que une fois qu'on a déterminé
un temps dans le ciel une fois qu'on a
une trajectoire de référence c'est un
calcul macroéconomique qui dit il manque
tant de centaines de millions pour
revenir sur la trajectoire bon donc ça
ça se passe en dehors du CEPS notre que
ça ne veut pas dire que nous sommes
purement observateurs notre contribution
à cet exercice nous la formulons au mois
de juillet
c'est à dire que à ce moment là sachant
que de toute façon nous allons avoir cet
exercice de régulation nous essayons
d'identifier des classes de produits sur
lesquels va pouvoir porter l'effort
demandé en matière de baisse nous le
faisons en regardant ce qu'est
l'ancienneté de ces produits ce qu'est
la dynamique de leurs dépenses et en
regardant aussi à quel moment ces
produits ont déjà fait l'objet d'un
exercice de baisse de prix s'ils l'ont
fait l'an dernier ou si ils n'ont pas
été
soumis à la régulation depuis trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans donc on essaie de
déterminer on détermine un certain
nombre de groupes de produits sur
lesquels il nous paraît possible et
opportun de faire porter un effort
d'économie et nous en informons à ce
moment-là le comité de pilotage de la
politique conventionnelle le CPPC qui se
réunit en juillet
à ce moment là nous n'avons pas
d'objectifs chiffrés mais nous
commençons à ce moment-là à examiner au
sein de ces groupes que nous avons
identifié
ce qui se passe médicament par
médicament ou ce qui se passe dans un
deuxième temps laboratoire par
laboratoire pour nous faire une idée de
ce qui est réalisable réalisable à
travers la politique conventionnelle
parce que on se dit on va devoir
négocier les baisses de prix qu'est-ce
qui nous paraît réalisable cette année
et ça c'est une contribution que nous
adressons traditionnellement aux
différents cabinets ministériels et bien
entendu d'abord aux membres du comité
économique
et que nous adressons que les membres
peuvent adresser à leurs différentes
autorités de tutelle ce n'est pas
quelque chose que nous communiquons au
laboratoire il s'agit d'un travail
technique préparatoire d'une
contribution au PLFSS donc nous essayons
d'apporter pour éclairer une décision
qui a une décision macroéconomique et
centrale nous essayons d'apporter une
contribution qui soit plus beau Tom up
on dit gouvernement voilà ce que ce qui
nous paraît et le gouvernement dispose
de cet élément en plus des éléments qui
se relèvent du de questions de bouclage
macroéconomique dans le dispositif de
régulation ce qui est prévu c'est que
au-delà de ce montant de baisse qui va
ainsi être arrêté par le gouvernement et
proposer au Parlement
la prévision est en exercice difficile
on n'est pas à l'abri d'une erreur de
prévision et il se peut que le montant
d'économie qui nous est demandé soit
finalement
inférieur à ce qui va être nécessaire
parce que la dépense sera spontanément
plus élevée que prévu ou le contraire
si il y a un dépassement c'est-à-dire on
nous dit fait 800 millions d'économies
par hypothèse nous obtenons 800 millions
d'économies sous forme de baisse de prix
et on constate un an plus tard que
malgré tout on est au dessus de la
trajectoire dans ce cas là il y a un
mécanisme de régulation supplémentaire
qui se déclenche c'est ce qu'on appelle
la clause de sauvegarde qui est censé
intervenir mais d'une manière je dirais
pas que c'est aléatoire mais en cas de
réalisation d'un aléa
sur la production et à ce moment là se
déclenche une demande de
une demande de contribution adressée aux
différents laboratoires en fonction de
leur chiffre d'affaires et cette année
en fonction aussi de leur contribution
en fonction de leur contribution à la
croissance c'est un deuxième étage de
régulation ce que nous faisons c'est de
la régulation conventionnelle ça c'est
de la régulation légale
nous préférons la régulation
conventionnelle l'amour parce que comme
je vous l'ai dit nous sommes le lieu de
la politique conventionnelle et parce
que nous avons la possibilité je dirais
de faire du sur mesure entre guillemets
quand on a un objectif à atteindre nous
800 millions cette année nous contactons
dès le mois d'août
tous les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
qui peuvent être concernés et nous leur
disons voilà nous allons avoir des
objectifs on va devoir faire des
demander des baisses de prix sur telle
classe vous avez des produits dans cette
classe nous envisageons de vous demander
une baisse de x%
qu'on peut objectiver de telle manière
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez et on
rentre à ce moment-là en négociation et
nous pouvons quand je disais nous
pouvons faire du sur mesure c'est à dire
qu'on essaie de mettre un peu
d'intelligence dans le système ce n'est
pas un coup de rabot on va dire au
laboratoire si on vous demande une
baisse sur tel produit c'est parce que
ce produit est dans tel classe il n'a
pas été régulé depuis tant d'années
depuis la concurrence s'est développée
il y a des concurrences certains sont
moins chers etc et donc à ce titre là on
peut vous demander telle baisse de prix
et le laboratoire nous répond il va nous
dire oui mais voilà quel est mon échec
quels sont mes échéances je vais avoir
un relais de croissance mais c'est pas
cette année c'est l'année d'après où je
vais perdre mon brevet à tel échéance et
ainsi de suite et on va essayer
d'obtenir l'objectif qui nous est donné
mais en disant familière familièrement
en essayant de voir avec les
laboratoires la façon pour que ça soit
le moins bête possible ou que ça fasse
le moins mal possible ou pour prendre le
plus possible en compte ce que sont les
circonstances particulières du
médicament et du laboratoire voilà
comment nous intervenons c'est un
exercice qui est difficile parce que on
parle de montant qui sont considérables
800 millions la difficulté qui a été
rencontrée cette année où la difficulté
dans laquelle nous sommes en ce moment
c'est que la clause de sauvegarde non
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que elle devait
se déclencher quand il y a la
réalisation d'un aléa sur la défense et
pour des montants qui en tout cas
jusqu'à présent a été relativement
limité cette clause de sauvegarde
intervient maintenant sur plusieurs
années consécutives et pour des montants
qui sont plus importants des montants
qui aujourd'hui atteignent à peu près le
même ordre de grandeur ou atteint en
tout cas cette année à peu près le même
ordre de grandeur que les économies que
nous demandons aux entreprises et dans
ce cas là c'est une difficulté d'une
part ça veut dire que globalement la
régulation une année donnée va être
beaucoup plus importante que le chiffre
que l'on commente les 800 millions
si vous avez 800 millions et que vous de
baisse de prix et 700 millions de
clauses de sauvegardes ça fait un
milliard 5 donc ça voilà ça appelle les
peut-être des questions différentes et
ça nous pose du point de vue de la
politique conventionnelle une difficulté
supplémentaire nous négociants il faut
que les entreprises et une incitation à
négocier et à trouver un accord avec
nous c'est beaucoup plus difficile quand
on va voir une entreprise et on lui
demande de baisser les prix de 10% on
lui dit on va faire 30 millions
d'économies sur votre laboratoire une
fois qu'on a regardé les différents
produits de votre portefeuille et le
laboratoire nous dit mais je pense que
derrière il va y avoir une clause de
sauvegarde qui va représenter un montant
équivalent donc à quoi bon signer un
accord avec vous puisque de toute façon
derrière je vais avoir une forme
d'imposition donc le fait que l'ordre de
grandeur de la régulation
conventionnelle et de la relation
législative que ces ordres de grandeur
soit proches et une consulter en soi du
point de vue de l'incitation pour les
laboratoires à jouer le jeu de la
politique conventionnelle voilà la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui et difficultés
supplémentaires je parle de difficulté
c'est pas une critique c'est un constat
pendant des années quand on avait un
objectif mettons je reste sur ces 800
millions pour pour illustrer on a un
objectif de 800 millions il faut que
nous déterminions je vous l'ai dit les
classes thérapeutiques sur lesquelles on
va faire porter l'effort la logique sur
laquelle on vivait et l'intuition c'est
que on va faire baisser le prix de
produits anciens et ça permettra de
financer l'arrivée de produits nouveaux
notamment de produits innovants et pour
certains un certain nombre d'entre eux
de produits qui sont
qui sont très onéreux
est-ce que cette est-ce que cela résume
bien l'ensemble de la démarche dans
laquelle on doit s'inscrire la réalité
est plus compliquée parce que au-delà de
la volonté de financer l'arrivée des
produits innovants on a des objectifs de
sécurité d'approvisionnement
on a des objectifs de préserver la
présence de fabrication en France et la
présence d'un approvisionnement
suffisant pour des produits matures et
des produits anciens mais
à un moment donné il va se poser la
question de l'assiette sur laquelle on
fait reposer les baisses de prix parce
que si on ne doit pas faire baisser les
prix tout de suite de produits qui
viennent d'arriver si on doit également
être très vigilant pour ne pas trop
faire baisser le prix de produits
anciens parce qu'on veut qu'il reste
qu'elles vont être les cibles
privilégiées donc c'est un c'est un
sujet qui a toujours existé mais qui je
crois prend des proportions plus
importantes aujourd'hui et c'est dans ce
cadre là que c'est inscrit le débat
auquel vous avez fait référence sur les
produits génériques pour lequel viennent
d'être décidés à moratoire alors le
débat sur les produits génériques n'est
pas nouveau et
il y a on sait que les fabricants de
produits génériques indiquent que par
leur seul existence ils apportent des
économies donc il se plaignent d'être
sujet à une régulation alors qu'ils
apportent déjà des économies et cette
année particulièrement dans le contexte
de hausse des coûts considérant que leur
marge sont relativement faibles
ils étaient particulièrement
réticents aux baisse de prix que nous
pouvions leur demander les baisses de
prix pour les génériques je disais tout
à l'heure elles sont beaucoup plus
encadrées par des règles on observe dans
le temps l'évolution de la substitution
des génériques
vis-à-vis des produits principes il y a
des règles assez strictes mais nous
avons deux exercices annuels de d'un
comité de suivi des génériques dans
lequel nous annonçons des des baisses de
prix sur tel ou tel groupe génériques et
cette année
les acteurs du secteur n'ont pas voulu
participer à la discussion parce que il
s'y opposait de manière frontale
bon
de notre point de vue c'est assez
dommage parce que c'est une négociation
c'était une négociation dans laquelle il
y avait de notre côté beaucoup de grains
à moudre parce que nous avions bien
conscience de ce qui était la situation
conjoncturelle actuelle mais ils ont
préféré ne pas se présenter à la table
des réunions ça nous a pas empêché de
travailler et il y a eu des annonces qui
ont été faites dans le cadre d'un comité
de pilotage sur les pénuries auxquelles
vous avez fait
référence décidant d'un moratoire sur
les baisses de prix alors nous avions
identifié nous avions 7 groupes de
produits génériques que nous avions mis
sur la table et négociations donc
c'était les 7 groupes dont les prix devc
cette année potentiellement on était
prêt à discuter je disais qu'il y avait
du grain à moudre on n'allait pas on
savait que on allait pas baisser les
prix sur ces 7 groupes et on est des
prêts à discuter en plus du montant des
baisses quoi qu'il en soit sur ces 7
groupes il y a un moratoire et nous
réexaminerons la situation plus tard
dans l'année quand nous disposerons de
la liste des fameux produits
critiques voilà voilà comment nous
procédons pour tenir l'objectif qui nous
est assigné cette année 800 millions
pour les médicaments 100 millions pour
les dispositifs médicaux produisent et
prestations
vous avez vous avez ensuite évoqué
le fait que nous pouvions être pris
entre deux feux les directives
gouvernementales et puis les
laboratoires
et vous avez évoqué vous avez commencé
d'évoquer les questions de transparence
sur ce que font les laboratoires et vous
avez cité un exemple qui est assez connu
et qui est assez spectaculaire je
le reconnais simplement
ce que vous avez ce que vous avez
directement pointé c'est la différence
entre un prix ou un coût de production
et un prix qui est revendiqué par le
laboratoire pour le produit
c'est effectivement une information
importante mais pour nous c'est une
information qui relève plus du contexte
que de la façon opérationnelle dont nous
fixons le prix d'un produit puisque ce
que nous dit la loi c'est que le prix du
produit on le fixe par rapport à
l'amélioration par rapport aux fameux
critères législatif le premier d'entre
eux étant l'ASMR donc ce que nous
faisons la première chose que nous
faisons quand nous devons tarifer un
produit c'est de regarder dans les avis
de la HAS de voir quelles sont les
comparateurs de voir quelles sont les
produits qui sont sur le marché c'est
une discussion qui est très complexe
parfois il n'y a pas de comparateur
direct parfois il y a une comparaison
par rapport à une stratégie
thérapeutique parfois on a le nombre de
comparateurs cliniquement pertinents
varie de 0 à
beaucoup quand on n'arrive pas à trouver
une solution on va chercher un
comparateur économiquement pertinent
mais une grande partie de la négociation
c'est ça consiste à déterminer un coût
de référence et c'est par rapport à ce
coût de référence qui peut être je
disais le cours d'un comparateur ou d'un
ensemble de comparateurs c'est par
rapport à ce coût de référence que nous
allons appliquer une majoration ou une
minoration c'est comme cela que nous
fonctionnons et le coût de production à
ce stade là nous ne le rendront pas
directement nous le rencontrons quand il
y a un problème et notamment dans la
situation mais qui est plutôt la
situation inverse de celle que vous
évoquiez c'est quand un laboratoire nous
dit pour mon produit le prix que vous me
proposez ça me permet pas de couvrir mes
coups donc c'est plutôt cette situation
là que nous avons à traiter les produits
les produits très onéreux
n'arrivent pas en nous détaillant ce
qu'est leur coût de production
une tendance récente qui nous interpelle
c'est quelque chose qui je pense que ce
n'était pas le cas il y a encore
quelques années c'est que de plus en
plus on a des laboratoires sur des
produits innovants et onéreux qui
arrivent avec une revendication de
primordiale donc le prix mondial on sait
que ça veut dire bien souvent c'est le
prix qui est leur principe aux
États-Unis
donc dans ces cas-là
nous ne prenons pas ce prix là pour
argent comptant qui serait justifié
parce que il a été décidé par une la
maison mère quelque part en dehors de
France nous appliquons je disais nous
négociants sans complaisance nous allons
regarder à quoi se produit se compare
quel est le coût de ces produits et
est-ce qu'on va le valoriser de 5-10%,
vous le minorez de 5%. c'est comme ça
que nous allons raisonner nous avons des
négociations qui sont complexes qui
peuvent durer longtemps d'autant plus
que pour ces différents produits
là aussi c'est une tendance je pense
assez récente et que l'on voit sur
différents produits notamment oncologie
on peut avoir une multiplicité ensuite
d'extension d'indications et donc
indication par indication nous allons
devoir tarifer en fonction de la valeur
thérapeutique alors que d'une indication
à l'autre les comparateurs ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes et les niveaux de de
coût
de traitement ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes donc on a des discussions très
compliquées là dessus je ne sais pas
comment on insérerait le coup de
production a priori uniforme dans une
négociation qui serait indication par
indication avec des valeurs
thérapeutiques et des comparateurs
différents tout ça est un exercice qui
est qui est très complexe
pour autant est-ce que je disais c'était
votre troisième point sur la
transparence le coût le coût de
production c'est bien qu'on puisse s'en
faire une idée
et et en même temps je vous ai dit il y
a un cas où clairement nous sommes dans
un raisonnement coût de production c'est
quand on nous dit les coûts de
production aujourd'hui sont telles que
je vais plus pouvoir commercialiser mon
produit donc dans ce cas là c'est
l'article 28 de la corde dont je peux
vous parler par ailleurs nous demandons
aux entreprises de documenter et nous
leur demandons de documenter très
précisément
quels sont les coûts et plus précisément
ce que ce qui nous intéresse c'est les
évolutions de coûts
si un laboratoire vient nous dire ça
devient impossible pour moi on va lui
dire très bien il y a trois ans c'était
possible aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
possible qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous
avez été confronté à un choc de coût
lequel vous documentez vous nous dites
tout ce qui a pu se passer et on va
regarder en premier parce que c'est le
facteur peut-être le plus le plus
évident et le plus nécessaire à
documenter
l'évolution de vos du coup des matières
premières c'est le point d'entrée
nous ce que nous allons faire à ce
moment là c'est que nous allons regarder
si c'est un produit dont on peut se
passer ou pas
si c'est un produit qui est un parmi
beaucoup d'autres pour une thérapie pour
une
pathologie donnée bon ben voilà c'est si
ce laboratoire n'est pas viable et que
les autres le sont enfin se produit
n'est pas viable et les autres leçons on
n'a pas forcément besoin
d'agir mais
vous voyez bien que à ce stade quand on
demande de documenter ce que font les
entreprises
elles nous c'est qu'elle nous donne leur
prix devient industriel elle nous donne
des informations qui sont vraiment
détaillées
ça nous fournit un élément de contexte
très important mais ce n'est pas à
partir de ça que nous prenons la
décision parce que
derrière le PRI ce qu'il y a c'est le
taux de marge et elles peuvent nous dire
le taux de marge est insuffisant
mais ça on peut pas rentrer dans ce
raisonnement là qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un taux de marché suffisant
il y a une entreprise qui va si une
entreprise nous dit moi mon taux de
marge c'est de 15% et ma maison mère
elle veut un taux de marge de 40%
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on peut lui
répondre on peut lui répondre que 40%
c'est trop mais que 30 c'est bien ou que
10 c'est bien quelle légitimité on
aurait là-dessus on n'a aucune
légitimité donc nous nous considérons
que notre légitimité ce n'est pas de
porter un avis sur le bon niveau d'un
taux de marge
c'est d'examiner quel est le problème
qui vient d'intervenir et qui fait que
ce qui était viable du point de vue de
la production ne le serait plus c'est
comme ça que l'on rentre dans le sujet
du coup de production et le coût global
c'est un élément de contexte important
et effectivement quand une entreprise
nous dit regardez mes marges deviennent
négatives on se dit là il y a vraiment
il y a vraiment un sujet donc regardons
de plus près ce qui s'est passé
pardon
oui oui on sait qu'il y a des seuils il
y a des seuils de vente à perte donc on
doit regarder dans ces cas-là ce qui se
passe mais le sujet que soulever la
madame le rapporteur c'était le cas
opposé le cas opposé c'est un produit
très onéreux
et dans ce cas les protections que nous
avons c'est de regarder ce que
représente les autres produits
et on va pas aller non plus faire
l'analyse produit par produit pour
savoir pour chacun d'entre eux quel est
le coût mais si vous avez un produit qui
est concurrent et dans le coût de
production est plus faible et qui avait
accepté les prix plus faibles on va
s'appuyer là-dessus pour faire baisser
la revendication du laboratoire en
question alors vous avez évoqué ensuite
des dispositions en fait qui sont des
dispositions législatives sur la
transparence et l'information qui doit
nous être communiqués sur les aides
publiques alors en fait ce n'est pas
enfin j'ai pas le texte sous les yeux
c'est pas les aides publics c'est les
investissements publics les
investissements publics c'est quelque
chose d'un peu compliqué qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un investissement public vous
me disiez le crédit d'impôt recherche
n'y est pas oui un crédit d'impôt c'est
pas un investissement public donc c'est
assez compliqué non non mais non mais le
terme si c'était le terme si c'était le
terme des aides publiques
là c'est porté qui est nettement c'est
un périmètre qui est plus large que
celui des investissements publics
et effectivement et effectivement donc
c'était le premier c'était la première
année que nous recevions des
déclarations alors peut-être que c'était
une phase de rodage peut-être
l'information n'était pas suffisante
nous n'avons pas eu toutes les réponses
des entreprises qui sont conventionnées
avec nous alors peut-être pour certaines
c'est parce que elle ne recevait pas
d'aide pour d'autres c'est parce
qu'elles étaient pas informés donc nous
nous relançons l'information
là-dessus mais effectivement on n'y a
pas le crédit d'un peu recherche et par
rapport à l'autre question que vous
posiez sur nos capacités à expertiser
nous n'avons pas au CEPS les moyens
d'expertiser nous n'avons ni la
compétence ni les moyens humains vous
posiez madame présidente une question
sur nos moyens alors il y a deux étages
puisqu'il y a l'équipe permanente donc
l'équipe permanente du CEPS nous entre
25 et 30 25 pour le médicament et le
dispositif médical
en incluant le secrétariat une
conseillère juridique
des rapporteurs généraux etc donc les
cadres évaluateurs qui travaillent sur
l'un qui font l'instruction des produits
pour le comité nous en avons quatre pour
le médicament et plus trois quatre pour
le dispositif médical mais mais
ça c'est l'équipe permanente le comité
qui se réunit toutes les semaines en
réunion plénière avec les membres que
j'ai évoqués et qui représentent des
organismes comme la CNAM la DSS la DGS
la DGE ils ont des ressources derrière
et ils travaillent si vous voulez nous
on fait l'interface dans les
négociations avec les entreprises et on
fournit une instruction des dossiers
donc je suis pas en train de vous dire
que nous ne voudrions surtout pas avoir
des ressources supplémentaires
évidemment nous voudrions avoir des
ressources supplémentaires mais il ne
faut pas non plus se dire que les
ressources du comité se limitent aux
ressources permanentes de cette équipe
qui a vocation à rester une équipe
légère
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire c'est
pas Jean-Patrick si tu as des
compléments sur ce point particulier des
déclarations effectivement si on avait
exprimé des réserves lors de
l'apparition de la mesure dans dans nos
auditions en pointant justement cette
absence de capacité de contrôle et
peut-être avec un raccourci un peu
brutal c'est-à-dire finalement les aides
publiques sont publiques donc elles ont
pas à être rassemblés quelque part les
organismes qui les distribuent peuvent
aussi faire état de ce qu'il distribuent
c'est une façon peut-être plus sûre
d'avoir la réponse mais si on devait
aller vers des vers une expertise
supplémentaire dans ce domaine pour de
bon la question des moyens se poserait
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le traitement
de déclarations ce qui est assez ce qui
s'est saisonnier ça c'est une fois dans
l'année s'il faut aller rechercher des
informations et les authentifier c'est
vraiment une activité totalement
différente sachant que aucune des aides
publiques qui sont recensés ou qui
pourraient l'être ne relève directement
de nous
le crédit un peu recherche alors
chrétien pour recherche il faudrait
savoir s'il y a ou pas des
des questions de sacrifice derrière mais
si vous voulez si on nous disait
recenser ou contrôlez le crédit pour
recherche
pour le CEPS je pense pas qu'on en est
vraiment la capacité ou la légitimité
une bonne partie des aides qui sont sous
forme d'investissement d'ailleurs ce qui
est ce qui a été déclaré c'est notamment
des aides qui passent par BPI France
j'imagine qu'il y a des prises de
participation de fonds propres de quasi
fonds propres etc mais ça ça se passe
plutôt du côté du SGPI ou du côté du
ministère de la Recherche
[Musique]
pour l'investissement c'est l'organisme
placé auprès de Matignon qui gère les
investissements d'avenir et le plan en
France 2030
une petite une petite précision puis je
vais laisser mes collègues parce que le
temps le temps tourne mais il y a deux
éléments vous enfin c'est quand même
assez subtil la différence entre j'avais
pas perçu investissement public et aide
publique c'est quand même voilà et quand
je dis subtil c'est gentil mais moi je
si vous voulez je suis quand même un peu
perplexe sur le fait que alors des aides
publiques et investissement public en
tout cas les aides publiques ne puissent
pas rentrer finalement dans l'évaluation
l'évaluation du prix ça je suis étonné
c'est ma première question de de
deuxième question que je ne vous ai pas
posé mais du coup qui découle de ce que
vous avez dit et je pense que mes
collègues vont aller plus à fond là
dessus puis vous aurez le questionnaire
mais c'est concernant les génériques
parce que sur sur les génériques si vous
voulez il y a des prix qui sont quand
même assez faibles or on a lu chacun et
chacune dans la presse ces derniers
temps que s'il y avait pénurie d'un
certain nombre de produits c'était du
fait pour certains d'entre eux d'un prix
trop bas et qui finalement faisait que
les industriels ne pouvaient pas s'en
sortir donc ils préfèrent arrêter la
production donc moi j'aimerais bien
quand même que vous soyez un peu plus
peut-être concret ou aller plus au fond
des choses parce que d'un côté il y a
ces génériques avec avec ce que je viens
de dire concernant les pénuries de
l'autre côté il y a des prix dit
innovants des produits pardon dit
innovants dont les prix battent toutes
rationalité on va dire mais mais c'est
pas toujours les mêmes labos si vous
voulez qu'ils sont qui sont concernés
par les par les produits nature et les
produits innovants donc comment
finalement on arrive à avoir une
une politique juste de la fixation des
prix qui ne va pas porter préjudice à
des produits qui sont qui sont matures
et qui finalement sont nécessaires pour
la pour la santé pour la santé publique
par exemple comme information
loméprazole aurait subi jusqu'à cette
baisse de prix en dix ans par exemple
donc effectivement là vous nous dites
que vous faites vous êtes attentif et
c'est très bien au fait que les mêmes
produits ne sont pas visés mais là ça
fait beaucoup cette baisse de prix en
disant bon je sais pas voilà donc est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un peu plus de
suppléments d'informations merci avant
que vous répondiez je propose que les
trois collègues qui ont demandé la
parole vous pose les questions pour que
vous puissiez et moi je compléterai
accessoirement
donc sénateur Bruno Belin
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur pour votre présentation vous
avez pas un boulot facile
parce que le prix mais ça va faire
rouler avec ce que je viens de dire la
rapporteur le prix du médicament et la
clé de cette souveraineté que l'on
recherche en matière de médicaments et
puis aussi d'une
[Musique]
d'une égalité à l'accès
un mot pour comprendre comment
fonctionne le bout de la chaîne le bout
de la chaîne c'est l'officine
on sait très bien aujourd'hui ça y est
10 000 études qui
restent propos on sait très bien
aujourd'hui que des officines en dessous
de 1,2 millions d'euros non pas d'avenir
par contre on sait très bien que les
officines trop grosses vont avoir des
difficultés à être reprises aujourd'hui
pour la première année pour la première
fois on est à moins 1000 pharmaciens en
France et donc cette question du chiffre
d'affaires des officines risque de
déboucher sur des déserts
pharmaceutiques on parlait des déserts
médicaux nous avons inventé en France
les déserts médicaux nous sommes en
train d'inventer les déserts
pharmaceutiques
donc ça c'est la première notion du prix
parce qu'il faut que les officines
effectivement dans leur proximité puisse
vivre ce qui veut dire aussi qu'il faut
que les répartiteurs puissent vivre moi
j'étais surprise je me suis permis
d'intervenir un soir au moment de la
discussion du PLFSS parce que j'ai
l'impression que le ministre qui était
au banc ne connaissait pas le
fonctionnement de la répartition en
France la répartition c'est ce qui
permet à toutes les spécialités même en
un exemplaire d'arrivée dans toutes les
officines de France même la plus
éloignée du monde dans un délai qui est
prévu par la loi donc vous imaginez que
la répartiteur ils ont juste besoin d'un
peu de trésorerie aussi et elle
sort sur le médicament donc à chaque
fois que vous baissez avec ces objectifs
vous l'avez dit cette fois du 800
millions
ça veut dire que c'est bien ancré en
vous à chaque fois que vous baissez
effectivement on joue sur ces leviers
de fin de chaîne qui sont essentielles
pour le malade parce qu'en fait ce qu'il
nous réunissent qui nous préoccupe
uniquement c'est cette maladie
et et sa santé on opère complètement et
l'exemple de
l'oméprazole et qu'on connaît depuis 20
ans
l'illustre bien on opère complètement la
notion de recherche et développement je
crois cet exemple là mais je vous en
prendre un autre parce que il faut qu'on
ait conscience nous de ce qui se passe
le mot pral quand il sort génial c'est
une révolution
la boîte pardon mais j'ai connu siècle
là et puis on a inventé derrière
l'Inexium puis voilà on a il y a eu de
la concurrence parce que finalement les
labos depuis le cimétidine à la taille
gamète ils ont compris que ils
développaient leurs produits en tapant
sur celui du concurrent puis et puis on
a toujours tiré vers le bas et puis on a
inventé effectivement tous les
génériques dont l'oméprazole donc pour
occuper des parts de marché il faut le
sortir aujourd'hui à
2,80 la boîte recherche et développement
les labos gagne 0 et donc vous ne pouvez
plus faire de recherche et développement
il n'y a pas
un labo aujourd'hui en France parce que
de toute façon si il fait un peu de
marge vous allez vous l'avez dit
lui-même vous-même je cherche votre
phrase vous allez lui mettre une sorte
de pénalité pour récupérer un peu de
voilà financer retrouver vos 800
millions je vais vous donner un autre
exemple d'une jeune pharmacienne
qui avait fait son stage de première
année dans mon officine donc des
territoires voilà deux points là
aujourd'hui à son niveau elle a 40 ans
et niveau de formation industrielle
exceptionnelle elle va travailler au
mois de septembre à Dubaï il y a pas un
laboratoire aujourd'hui qui est capable
en France de financer ce type de
professionnels de santé engagé dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique elle va à
Dubaï on est en train de laisser ça on a
vu l'exemple aussi avec des grands
chercheurs partir États-Unis etc nous
perdons aujourd'hui notre matière grise
pharmaceutique parce que nous sommes pas
capables en France de de financer ça
vous vous parlez des efforts du c'est
des comparateurs sur le service médical
rendu mais quand vous avez un médicament
innovant qui sort on a un exemple en
tête sur le cancer du sein
il y a pas de comparateur médicalement
rendu possible puisque de toute façon on
n'a pas de points vous parlez des
médicaments anciens mais ils sont tous
génériques donc voilà il y a cette
cette compétition où il faut garantir un
prix je vais vous donner un dernier
exemple qui était avant covid avant
l'Ukraine etc donc faut pas nous dire
que ça aussi changer le célestène good
un truc à deux balles
mais que bien utile pour des tas de
maman
on l'avait laissé partir en Egypte et
les stocks sont repartis par
la Chine on a découvert ça que quand il
a fallu récupérer des stocks les notices
à l'intérieur étaient effectivement en
langue du pays d'origine donc vous voyez
que le prix du médicament il est
essentiel parce que dans les
revendications que nous allons avoir
il faut que nous ayons un stock de
sécurité en France on sait bien rendu
compte que on nous dit je vais en
prendre deux exemples dans tous pardon
d'être long
j'ai l'impression qu'on est loin du
terrain venez vivre Président vous
verrez comment ça fonctionne mais on
nous a dit il y a pas assez de la voxym
ici il n'y a pas assez de part stamol
c'est des choses qu'on sait faire depuis
60 70 ans donc il faut qu'il y a un
stock de sécurité le stock de sécurité
faut le financer qu'il finance ça peut
pas être les officines ça peut pas être
les répartiteurs donc si cette tôle labo
les financiers avec le système de
répartition ce qui est la clé parce
qu'il faut les avoir à disponibilité à
disposition évidemment il faut que ça se
joue aussi sur le prix du médicament
pardon d'avoir été long
mais je vous invite à venir quelques
jours avec nous voir comment ça
fonctionne sur le terrain et c'est vrai
que c'est difficile
merci chers collègues Patricia oui merci
moi je vais venir sur le volet Europe
parce que ça seul on va pas loin mais
quand on est à plusieurs on arrive quand
même mieux vous avez parlé de Sauve de
ce clause de sauvegarde et puis les
aléas des dépenses surtout que vous
devez faire des économies alors je sais
qu'il y a des contraintes partout ça
fait depuis trois ans qu'on voit bien
comment ça se passe je voulais savoir
comment ça se passe chez vos homologues
dans les autres pays Allemagne et
Espagne et puis l'Italie qui sont quand
même de notre proximité
est-ce qu'on travaille ensemble où
chacun ajustement des contraintes
différentes
et surtout l'approvisionnement des
médicaments innovants il est vrai que la
France souvent elle a besoin de
médicaments innovants c'est très
difficile parfois elle n'arrive pas à
les avoir parce que ben elle est bien
seule et qu'il y a pas le poids européen
comment est-ce que on avance dans le
dans ce marché là surtout à savoir que
par exemple
on sait que la myotrophie spinale
infantile une injection coûte 2 millions
d'euros si on était peut-être
plus ensemble on pourrait avoir
peut-être de meilleur
prix et parfois j'ai l'impression que
vraiment la France parfois
elle propose mais souvent seule et qu'on
n'est pas on n'a pas un travail en
commun européen
je resterai peut-être pas parce que je
dois aller au groupe on a des réunions
politiques et aujourd'hui mon Président
n'est pas là et c'est moi qui le
remplace donc
exceptionnellement ça va être dur de
remplacer François mais Alexandra
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues messieurs j'avais une question
aussi sur le le travail avec l'Europe
comme notre collègue patricia a posé la
question mon intervention sera encore
plus rapide
j'avais une question donc sur la
politique de fixation des prix menés par
la France et je voulais avoir je voulais
vous poser une question finalement un
peu directe
justement cette politique de fixation
des prix finalement est-ce qu'elle ne va
pas nous défavoriser alors ma question
est-ce que vous pensez que
l'augmentation des prix du médicament
finalement peut enrayer la crise
actuelle et puis j'avais mis une autre
question qui était plus prospective la
pénurie de médicaments on l'a vu est un
enjeu majeur qui fait l'objet d'ailleurs
de nombreux rapports il m'a parlé donc
on va dire crucial de comprendre comment
votre comité travail pour
identifier les causes profondes est-ce
que vous pouvez nous indiquer
quel signaux même faible en tout cas
vous sont remontés qui annonçait ou
laisser pressentir une crise à venir et
puis fort de ces enseignements bien sûr
qu'elles sont les outils ou quelle
méthode utiliser vous en tout cas
aujourd'hui pour surveiller et prévenir
la pénurie je vous remercie
et donc Corinne Imbert merci madame la
Présidente une question très courte
merci messieurs pour vos propos
la clause industrielle que vous avez
évoquée à plusieurs reprises
à votre avis
sous quelle échéance qu'elle délai
combien de temps il faudra pour qu'on
envoie les bienfaits vous allez me dire
ça dépend de la capacité des entreprises
pharmaceutiques à relocaliser dans notre
pays mais au regard des échanges et dans
la mesure où cette clause est nouvelle
dans les accords notamment
conventionnel que vous avez avec LEM
quand est-ce qu'on enverra des bienfaits
j'allais dire pour éviter les ruptures
et pour essayer d'avoir
un peu plus de sécurité dans nos stocks
de médicaments dans notre pays
aussi et moi je vais juste compléter
pour juste rebondir sur la question que
j'ai posé tout à l'heure
[Musique]
vu le dimensionnement du comité vous
allez donc besoin de vous abdosser sur
l'expertise des membres du comité
finalement donc une expertise
externalisée mais interne quelque part
par des structures qui sont des
organismes qui sont jugés partis et
donc vous vous avez précisé vous ne
souhaitiez pas grossir mais quelque part
avoir une forme d'indépendance en tout
cas d'autonomie un avis souverain y
compris sur cette question
industrielle et économique est-ce que
vous pensez pas compte tenu du fait que
ça vient d'arriver dans les contraintes
il serait nécessaire de renforcer vos
équipes dans ce domaine
et ma deuxième question est le corps
était l'air de celle là
l'ex a été donné pour l'oméprazole des 7
baisses on sait que l'outil de
production il se il se fonde il se
construit se structure sur les
médicaments anciens
et que si on ne maintient pas les
structures de fabrication des
médicaments anciens parce qu'on ne
prescrit plus ou parce qu'il y a plus
aucun intérêt économique pour le
laboratoire à ce moment-là on ne
maintient pas dans le territoire les
savoir-faire et l'outil industriel et
donc pour les nouveaux médicaments on
est plus en capacité de les produire
[Musique]
merci pour ces questions à chaque fois
derrière chacune de ces questions il y a
la place pour un débat passionnant
il nous reste encore un peu de temps ou
pas parce que j'ai oublié de vous poser
la question au tout début de savoir
bon
madame le rapporteur sur le sur le sujet
des investissements publics et des aides
publiques pardonnez-moi d'avoir insisté
sur la notion d'investissement mais
sachez que on le fait systématiquement
dans un autre dans un autre cas de
figure nous avons des nous avons des
clauses qui attribuent des avantages
conventionnels
à des entreprises au titre de leurs
investissements
la première mise au point qui est
parfois nécessaire vis-à-vis de
certaines entreprises c'est de leur
demander qu'est-ce qu'elles appellent un
investissement
il ne suffit pas d'avoir dépensé de
l'argent sur le territoire pour que ça
s'appelle un investissement donc nous
sommes très vigilants sur ce qu'est un
investissement vis-à-vis des entreprises
en leur disant écoutez vous voulez qu'on
récompense un investissement mais est-ce
bien en investissement et c'est curieux
que ce soit une entreprise qui ne sache
pas ce que c'est qu'un investissement
vous qui en a une vision ou un petit peu
vague donc on a cette attitude là de non
complaisance sur le sujet vis-à-vis des
entreprises mais de notre côté si des
entreprises nous disent j'ai reçu ta
lettre mais c'est pas une aide c'est pas
un investissement public c'est autre
chose bon voilà il faut reconnaître
aussi que si on parle d'investissement
que ce soit pour une entreprise ou pour
l'État le mot a une valeur précise
vous m'avez demandé vous avez remarqué
vous avez fait une remarque je vais y
arriver en disant que c'est un peu
dommage que ces aides ou ses
investissements peu importe ne rentrent
pas dans l'évaluation du prix très bien
alors moi j'aurais une question en
retour comment vous voudriez que ça
entre dans l'évolution dans l'évaluation
du prix plus précisément tu poses une
question naïve dans quel sens
si jamais un médicament arrive devant le
CEPS et que on voit à travers une
enquête qui aurait donné des résultats
précis que ce produit a bénéficié
d'investissement public c'est-à-dire que
d'une certaine manière les pouvoirs
publics ont considéré qu'il y avait un
intérêt stratégique sur ce produit là si
j'ai cette information que
souhaiteriez-vous que nous en fassions
au CEPS faut-il dire puisque ce produit
est stratégique il faut lui accorder des
avantages supplémentaires ou est-ce que
le CEPS devrait dire il a déjà bénéficié
d'une aide publique qui ne viennent pas
nous demander un effort supplémentaire
je ne sais pas quelle est la tente donc
outre les difficultés techniques que
j'ai évoquées est-ce que pardon est-ce
que on peut l'expertiser maintenant
il faudrait il faudrait dans votre
dans votre logique est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez que on ajoute un avantage à
une aide qui est intervenue en amont ou
est-ce que vous voudriez que considérant
qu'une aide a déjà été donnée il faut
surtout pas en donner une autre
pour moi c'est pas c'est pas aussi
simple je pense que le sujet dont je le
présente de manière
un peu légère mais c'est un vrai sujet
alors dans ce cas là si vous voulez si
on réfléchit ensemble c'est un critère
qui me semble intéressant à prendre en
compte c'est un peu comme dans le
système si vous voulez il y a des
entreprises que je vais appeler page
obligatoire des entreprises sur le
médicament mais il y a des entreprises
dites vertueux c'est-à-dire qui ont une
politique au niveau de l'emploi
d'encouragement qui ont une politique
qui respecte égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes etc il y a un certain nombre
de de critères par exemple on a on est
les représentants des collectivités ici
au Sénat on a tous eu où on a encore des
mandats
qui sont ou locaux ou départementaux ou
régionaux et les aides qui sont
attribuées par ces collectivités assez
assez à ces entreprises vont tenir
compte d'un certain nombre de critères
pour justement
favoriser cette politique de l'emploi il
comprendre que au niveau du médicament à
partir du moment où il y a des aides qui
sont accordés et qui sont conséquentes
je parle pas voilà là on est sur et bien
je pense qu'il faut effectivement en
tenir compte par rapport aux exigences
quand elles sont
par exemple sur les produits innovants
vertigineux quand les les prix sont ce
que j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire on est sur des milliers
d'euros par rapport à voilà c'est ça
tenir compte de ça comme étant comment
j'ai dit quoi un million pardon mille
millions millions d'euros donc voilà je
dis que c'est un des critères je dis pas
voilà moi ça me paraît toujours
paradoxal de ne pas tenir compte de cet
élément là qui fait partie de la
politique du médicament
[Musique]
je comprends bien et de manière générale
et là où je veux rejoindre sans peine
c'est que tout ce qui contribue à nous
donner une information plus large sur un
produit et donc à mieux comprendre la
revendication ou à mieux être en mesure
de la Challenger c'est quelque chose qui
est bien venu de même lorsqu'on avait
les discussions sur le sur le coup de
production même si c'est pas à nous de
déterminer un taux de marge savoir si le
taux de marge est énorme aussi il est
faible c'est une information de la même
façon savoir si le produit a été jugé
déjà stratégique par les pouvoirs
publics à notre moment c'est quelque
chose qui peut être une information
intéressante mais là on n'est pas
directement dans une application
mécanique ou telle investissement et
bien justifierait que le de manière
mécanique le CEPS accorde ou retranche
tel ou tel avantage
alors vous avez parlé de politique
vertueuse je vous dirai c'est un sujet
auquel on sera confronté on regarde les
investissements on regarde
notamment enfin d'abord les
investissements en capacité de
production
on va avoir le cas de plus en plus je
l'espère d'investissement vert entre
guillemets mais voilà le la qualité
environnementale du process n'est pas
explicitement l'un des critères qui
figurent aujourd'hui dans la loi on
essaie d'en tenir compte c'est un
élément de contexte que nous avons mais
ça ne figure pas directement dans la loi
alors plusieurs d'entre vous vous madame
la rapporteur vous monsieur le sénateur
avait évoqué soit les produits
génériques soient au-delà des produits
anciens dont me semble-t-il dans les
arguments que vous mettiez en avant la
caractéristique commune et d'avoir a
priori de faible marge
alors deux éléments de réponse d'avoir
aussi dans les dans les dans les dans
les exemples que vous citiez vous citer
des produits anciens mais qui sont
aujourd'hui anciens et qualifie de
mature sur lesquelles on a effectué déjà
des baisses de prix et qui aujourd'hui
ont peut-être des marges assez faibles
mais c'est aussi des produits qui ont
été innovants et qui a un moment donné
avait des marches beaucoup plus élevées
et qui ont eu des efforts des
investissements y compris des
investissements de recherche mais dont
on ne peut pas penser que avec le temps
ils ont été quand même dans une large
menu dans une large mesure amortie donc
qu'il baisse apprécient une question de
dosage c'est une question de dosage
mais en même temps
d'anciennes produits ou produits nature
mais c'est pas ça de façon
malades c'est qu'ils puissent obtenir le
médicament dont ils ont besoin on a
manqué d'amoxicilline
avec des milliers de cas de surinfection
pulmonaire enfin divers voilà enfin
pardon
on manque de choses qui sont qui
dépassent bien cette notion là et on a
manqué par stamol alors pas ça qui comme
ça comme ça a été comme ça a été dit il
faut regarder il faut s'assurer de notre
point de vue que la politique de prix
que nous conduisons ne vient pas
aggraver des situations mais les
situations de pénurie ne se résument pas
à un sujet de prix si c'était le cas non
non non si c'était le cas
si c'était le cas on n'aurait pas
des prix qui sont qui sont bas
on n'aurait pas de tension ou de rupture
sur certains produits aux États-Unis
dans d'autres pays européens dans tous
les pays en même temps alors que les
systèmes de prix y sont différents et
même chez nous et même chez nous les
prix qui sont qui sortent du CEPS c'est
une partie des produits la plupart des
produits hospitaliers sont à prix libres
sous forme d'appel d'offres pour les
produits de GHS et à l'hôpital et c'est
là que vous avez peut-être le plus de
pénurie c'est pas parce que le CEPS les
a fixés à des prix à des
niveaux trop bas donc le prix on doit
veiller à ne pas aggraver une situation
si on se retrouve avec des produits
anciens matures dont les prix ont déjà
baissé à plusieurs reprises qui ont un
taux de marge très faible et que à ce
moment là
intervient un choc de coût qui va faire
basculer dans des conditions où
l'exploitation n'est plus possible là si
jamais on laisse faire ce genre de
situation on a un rôle négatif d'où
l'enjeu pour nous de mobiliser davantage
et c'est ce que nous viennent nous
demander le gouvernement il vient de le
demander aux membres de mobiliser
davantage l'article 28 de la corcadre
qui est un article qui nous permet de
procéder à des hausses de prix s'il y a
des risques de retrait et du coup là
j'en viens à la question que vous êtes
plusieurs à avoir formulé sur sur la
façon de pardon
on va essayer un risque de retrait s'il
y a un risque de retrait ce que nous ce
que nous demandons ce que nous écrivons
c'est que s'il y a un risque de retrait
les laboratoires concernés nous le
disent et à ce moment-là on a un outil
qui nous permet si on considère que
parce que encore une fois on prend pas
au pied de la lettre tout ce qui nous
est tout ce qui est revendiqué si on
considère que 1 il y a un enjeu et que
deux c'est un enjeu qui correspond à une
hausse de coût enfin qui un enjeu de
santé pardon et que le problème est un
problème de coût à ce moment-là on peut
procéder à une hausse on avait dans la
corps cadre donc un article si vous
reportez à la corde c'est l'article 28
qui était un article dont on pouvait
faire une lecture relativement mécanique
on demandait de documenter on demandait
que le besoin soit pour être éligible il
fallait que le besoin soit non couvert
qu'il n'y ait pas de comparateur ou un
seul qui est un poste de coût qui est
subi un choc ce que nous demande le
gouvernement dans le contexte actuel
c'est de faire une application plus
souple de cet article et en particulier
d'un alinéa de cet article qui à côté de
la démarche un peu mécanique s'en remet
à une appréciation du comité et quand je
parle d'appréciation du comité
nous nous essayons là aussi de croiser
deux approches une approche qui soit
vraiment santé publique pour apprécier
l'enjeu de santé et là nous nous
accueillons beaucoup sur les ressources
et les compétences de la Direction
générale de la santé et une approche qui
soit une approche sur la chaîne de
valeur et là nous nous sur les tensions
éventuelles et là nous nous appuyons sur
d'une part des analyses des constats qui
sont faits par la NSM dans la DGS à la
tutelle et d'autre part sur un examen de
la chaîne de valeur ajoutée pour
lesquelles nous demandons à la DGE de
nous apporter son expertise donc c'était
aussi pour illustrer madame la
Présidente la question des moyens que
nous pouvons mobiliser
la CNAM est présente et fortement
présente dans dans les dans nos dans nos
réunions je vous ai dit à la trois voies
et là des oui elle met à disposition des
ressources et de la compétence
sur les sujets si vous voulez le sujet
en jeu de santé publique on s'appuie
beaucoup sur la DGS sur le risque sur
des tensions qui seraient déjà apparues
ou des ruptures qui seraient envisagées
en s'appuie sur la NSM et sur la
description des chaînes de valeur on
s'appuie sur la DGE pour nourrir les
délibérations du
du comité donc on nous demande
aujourd'hui d'appliquer cet article 28
d'une manière plus flexible on va
notamment
pour cette aliné à 5 enfin peu importe
le détail mais qui qui donne la
possibilité d'utiliser l'article même
pour un produit qui a d'autres
comparateurs
mais pour lequel on considère qu'il y a
un véritable enjeu de santé publique à
un moment donné on pourra mobiliser cet
article par exemple pour les hausses
ciblées que vous je crois que c'est vous
qui les avez cités madame je ne sais
plus Léo se cibler sur les produits
génériques que nous a évoqué le
gouvernement donc aujourd'hui donc nous
avons
nous avons une boîte à outils qui a été
complétée on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de
l'article 65 mais c'est une nouveauté
puisque ça nous donne la possibilité
d'intervenir directement sur le niveau
de prix auparavant les leviers que nous
actionions c'était de la stabilité de
prix essentiellement qui protège contre
une baisse de prix par exemple
maintenant on a la possibilité
directement
d'accorder une un niveau de prix plus
élevé ça c'est l'article 65 et pour des
médicaments qui sont déjà présents et
sur lesquels il y a un risque de retrait
nous avions cet article 28 nous l'avons
toujours et nous allons l'utiliser de
manière je dirais plus volontariste en
fonction de priorité stratégiques
notamment sur les produits à faible
marge sur les produits
génériques et sur les produits
considérés comme critique pour
lesquelles nous attendons de disposer
d'une liste en principe à la fin du mois
de mai
très bien alors vous m'aviez demandé
madame combien de temps puisque voilà je
j'évoquais l'article 65 combien de temps
pour avoir en voir les effets
c'était le PLFSS 2022 et c'est quelque
chose qui n'avait pas encore été mise en
œuvre derrière il y avait des questions
techniques assez compliquées nous avons
nous y avons travaillé nous avons
maintenant un mode opératoire nous avons
commencé à communiquer dessus nous
allons préciser la façon dont nous
allons l'utiliser donc c'est un outil
qui devient opérationnel dans les
prochaines semaines
[Musique]
les bienfaits c'est
oui mais oui mais on pourra pas dire
voilà c'est le c'est le 15 avril que les
effets se sont fait sentir mais
je pense que c'est les enfin si vous
voulez l'effet sur le prix va être
immédiat quand on négociera négociera un
produit on lui accordera un avantage de
prix si c'est ce qui fait basculer la
décision de maintien ou de retrait d'une
production ça sera un effet immédiat
mais je pense que ça concourt de manière
plus générale à une politique
d'attractivité et une politique
d'attractivité on peut pas en voir les
effets du du jour au lendemain là où on
peut avoir un effet beaucoup plus rapide
c'est des articles du type l'article 28
parce que là l'entreprise vient et nous
dit voilà je n'y arrivais plus je vais
me retirer en expertise on regarde on
demande la documentation et si on
applique une hausse de prix là on
l'applique très rapidement et ça peut
avoir un effet rapide sur le fait qu'une
production soit maintenue
[Musique]
vous m'aviez demandé madame la
Présidente je voulais surtout pas ne pas
répondre à aux questions de la
présidente sur les questions d'expertise
des membres vous avez qualifié de juger
partie
vous avez en partie répondu
ouais mais je voulais ajouter quelque
chose moi je
moi je préfère dire que les différents
membres ont des compétences spécifiques
et peut-être des tropices des angles
d'approche un peu spécifiques c'est pas
le même pour la DSS et pour la DGE mais
ça veut dire que on peut sur un sujet
donné demandez une expertise aux membres
qui est le plus compétent dans cette
dimension là et notre rôle on
vice-président et au Président c'est
face à ces tropiesmes individuels des
différents membres de rappeler en
permanence quels sont les orientations
générales qui nous sont données par le
gouvernement puisque nous orientations
sont signés par trois ou quatre
ministres suivants les configurations
gouvernementales et ces orientations
générales qui doivent transcender les
tropismes spécifiques propres à chacune
des directions enfin des membres
et je n'ai pas dit que je ne souhaitais
pas grandir je pense qu'on a vocation à
rester une équipe légère on pourrait
avoir bénéfice à plus d'expertise dans
tel ou tel domaine
la dimension économique et individuelle
prend devient importantes et donc ça
fait pas partie de du j'allais dire du
de l'histoire classique de
fonctionnement des arbitrages du CEPS
donc
nous avons maintenant de plus en plus de
clauses celle que je viens de d'évoquer
nous avons de plus en plus de gosses qui
effectivement
requiert une expertise de nature
industrielle
on vous remercie beaucoup de
la qualité de vos réponses vous allez
donc on va vous faire parvenir un
questionnaire comme on l'a précisé en
introduction auquel
on vous demandera de réponse et répondre
à notamment la question européenne qui
avait été soulevée par par ma collègue
qui est parti et qui fait partie quand
même des sujets le prix du médicament
européen etc etc ça ne pratique quand
même des sujets qui sont assez
régulièrement évoqués
voilà sur ce point madame la Présidente
on a peu de rapports européens
et la DGS a animé
au sein de la PFE un groupe des groupes
de travaux à participer à des groupes de
travail et c'est peut-être la direction
qui est la plus avancée dans la
connaissance des mécanismes
collaboratifs et dans ces échanges et
dans ces groupes de travail européen
auquel j'ai moi-même participé notamment
durant la
PFE on a beaucoup d'échanges et qui sont
des échanges sur les méthodologies sur
les approches sur les politiques mais
pas directement sur le prix de tel ou
tel produit
le prix de tel ou tel produit ailleurs
en Europe nous l'examinons dans le cadre
de la négociation de tel ou tel produit
parmi les avantages conventionnels que
nous pouvons accorder à certains
produits il y a le fait de les aligner
sur un niveau européen donc là on
regarde des niveaux de prix pour autant
qu'on puisse en avoir la connaissance et
en général on a la connaissance que du
prix facial Lee Price et pas le prix net
de la même façon que nos partenaires
européens on la connaissance de nos prix
faciaux mais pas des prix nettes que
nous pratiquons en France et donc mais
dans les groupes de travail dont on
parlait là on échange sur la
méthodologie comment doit-on tarifer un
produit qui vient revendiquer 2 millions
d'euros voire plus maintenant donc ça
c'est des sujets que l'on peut avoir en
Europe mais on va pas échanger
directement sur
et chez vous quel est le prix net que
vous lui avez proposé
de toute façon je
propose qu'on s'arrête là je vous
remercie beaucoup et donc on attend les
les réponses écrites à votre
questionnaire je lève la séance et nous
nous retrouvons à 13h30 donc en salle
monorie pour le dire l'audition du
directeur général de la santé nous ne
manquerons pas de tenir compte de votre
avis de fin de l'audition merci beaucoup